the Joe Rogan experience that's what's
really interesting about churches
tax-exempt baby they're doing the
government's work the government's like
you're doing such a good job keeping
these people in line here you go free
free no taxes bro you're good you're
good
like imagine the government looking at
televangelist going well seems legit you
definitely have the Lord's words in mind
and definitely not making a ton of money
in the loophole so yeah yeah for sure
keep that tax exempt status seems good
seems super solid imagine imagine that
like somewhere someone must have had
that conversation whether or not they
should have tax-exempt status like at
what point in time you know like how
about the Catholic Church how many sex
scandals how many pedophile scandals
does it take before you lose tax-exempt
status is there like a million how many
cases how many cases do you need I get
what point in time do you go hey maybe
you guys should [ __ ] it at least pay
taxes you know maybe that's the deal
that cut your child odd for the kids but
you got to start paying taxes well
they're not prosecuting them because
people aren't screaming for it what's
really interesting is that if you look
at some of the things that people are
really rallying about today what you
would call like social justice warriors
people are rallying around so many
different causes those those people that
are rallying around all these causes
supporting and Tifa doing this you know
protecting this and going after that
what they're not doing is going after
that church how come they're not
shouting from there if you really want
justice if you really want to do good in
the world
when you want to stop the pedophiles
when you want to stop that if you didn't
you don't see that it's too scary for
people so big they get their own country
the Vatican is basically a country they
have their own passport it's dark it's
dark when people look like that they
feel like they're doing progress and
then you know do you not stop on that
you're not you know like your concern is
what what's your concern the sculpture
of the Resurrection and seen that no
evil what is that again it's supposedly
it's supposed to be Jesus rising from
the dead but it looks like
zombie looks it looks like hell and see
that yeah it sculpture of the
resurrection yeah dis mm and then they
got a circus Earp n't cathedral where it
looks like your serpent head it's crazy
stuff you've been no but I've seen it on
YouTube you've been an idiot it Aaliyah
no you should go dude is insane
it's so insane the Vatican is so insane
it's absolutely worth the wait up you
went into the Vatican yeah it's amazing
the artwork is off the charts you can't
believe it st. Peter's Basilica that's
it right there
who [ __ ] me yeah that's supposed to
be it's something about bro that looks
represents Christianity in front of
Marilyn Manson's house this is their
beautiful people beautiful yeah make a
great photos that would be an amazing
gate right if you like the ultimate
horror fiction writer like if Stephen
King bought a house in the Hollywood
Hills yeah that was as gate look up this
the resurrection feed there's a serpent
Cathedral Vatican that's it that's crazy
dude it's looks like a snake so there's
a there's a thing in there called st.
Peter's Basilica man you know you've
never seen anything yeah that's their
life right there right so look at that
looks like come on man that's crazy
come on man that's crazy it has the eyes
of a snake the head of a snake and the
fangs that is very very you can see that
resurrection thing right that's amazing
that's amazing dude if you were dating a
girl like Jesus right there dude I don't
see Jesus anywhere if you were dating a
girl and she's really into witchcraft
you'd want to [ __ ] her right right in
between baby I want to take you to the
Vatican where sneaked away I'm gonna
bribe somebody that's scary imagine they
just had a bed that you could borrow and
what if what if the Pope is really the
king of the world let him out there Oh
what's crazy what if he is though
definitely yes